>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Hi, there.
>> Hi.
>> I just think it's
pretty miraculous
that we haven't actually
started this program yet,
but you all got quiet and it's
like we're going
to start a program.
Thank you for that cue.
You guys are terrific.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, go ahead, clap.
All right.
So welcome.
My name is Lee Ann Potter.
I direct Educational Outreach
here at the Library of Congress.
And it is my absolute
pleasure to welcome you
to this very special event.
And I really do need to
make a very special shout
out to our students.
It's cold out there.
Thank you for braving the cold.
I know that you know
that today you're here
at the Library of Congress.
But did you know that here
on Capitol Hill there are
actually three buildings
that make up the
Library of Congress?
Did you know that?
>> No.
>> So there's a building
behind us
and it's named for John Adams.
And we have a building
next to us
and it's named for
James Madison.
And the building that you're
in right now is named
for Thomas Jefferson.
We could say that these three
men were former U.S. presidents.
We could say that these
men were attorneys.
men were lawmakers,
that they were farmers,
that they were gardeners,
that they were fathers,
that they were husbands;
because as you know,
an individual is
never just one thing.
And I happen to know
that you guys go
to a school that's also
named for somebody.
Who is that?
>> Harriet Tubman.
>> That's right.
Duh. Yeah, you guys go to a
school named for Harriet Tubman,
and Harriet Tubman is exactly
who our program is
all about today.
It is my hope that by the end of
our program that what you know
about Harriet Tubman
is a little bit greater
than what you currently
know about Harriet Tubman.
And so at the end
of our program,
I'm going to see how much
you've been paying attention
and what you know about her.
But let me talk to
you a little bit
about the run of our show today.
In addition to me,
you're going to be hearing
from four additional speakers.
And at the end of our
program, you'll be able
to ask questions
of our speakers.
With us today, we have a
senator, we have an author,
we have an illustrator, and we
have a descendent of Harriet;
and all four of them are
going to visit with you.
It is my pleasure to introduce
you to our very first speaker.
I'm introducing you to
Senator Chris Van Hollen.
He happens to be one of
my senators [laughs].
[ Applause ]
Senator Van Hollen is
one of two senators
who represent the people
of the state of Maryland.
But there's more.
He is also a lawyer and
a husband and a fisherman
and a father -- and I had to
do some digging on this --
a bicyclist, and
a world traveler.
Senator Van Hollen,
thank you for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you, Lee Ann,
and thank you for that research.
And I really want to
thank you most of all
for the work you do here at
the Library of Congress as part
of the educational program
and especially the
Young Readers program.
And it's great to see all of you
come to the Library of Congress.
And this is one of our
great national treasures,
this library, and I'm really
pleased that you're putting
on programs like this
for our students.
And welcome to all the students
from Harriet Tubman
Elementary School.
So I represent the
state of Maryland
in the United States Senate.
And my Senate office
is not far from here.
And when you go into my
office, we have a wall
that has photographs
and portraits of people
from Maryland who have
changed America for the better
and changed the world
for the better.
And when you go into our office,
you will see a portrait there
of Frederick Douglass.
And the reason I mention
Frederick Douglass is because,
like Harriet Tubman, he
was a great abolitionist --
fought to end slavery --
he was also from Maryland,
and he was born 200 years ago
this coming Valentine's Day.
So we're going to be
celebrating the 200th birthday
of Frederick Douglas.
And the Library of Congress has
an exhibit devoted to the work
that Frederick Douglass did.
So also on the wall of my office
with the great Marylanders
who've changed history is a
photograph of Harriet Tubman.
And it's a picture
of Harriet Tubman
when she was more elderly.
And you may have heard that
the Library of Congress,
together with the African
American Museum on History
and Culture, recently
came upon a new portrait
of Harriet Tubman
when she's younger.
And I'm looking forward
to having both portraits
of Harriet Tubman on
our wall as you come
into our Maryland office.
And I'm really pleased to
be here with two individuals
who have written a wonderful
book about Harriet Tubman.
You'll be hearing
from them in a bit.
But to Lesa Cline-Ransome,
the author, and her husband,
the illustrator -- a great
husband and wife team --
Lesa Cline and James Ransom,
who've written the book you're
going to be talking about today,
and were very fortunate
to have them with us.
And to Ms. Tina Wyatt,
great to have a descendent
of Harriet Tubman with
us today and, I can see,
keeping the spirit alive.
And the reason it's so
important to gather and to talk
about Harriet Tubman is
because she did change the world
for the better.
And we should learn
that history,
and we should also learn
from her bravery and courage
as we address some of the
challenges we face today.
If you haven't been to
Maryland's Eastern shore
in Dorchester County,
you'll find the birthplace
of Harriet Tubman.
She was born into slavery.
And when she was very
young, she wasn't allowed
to learn to read and write.
But she knew she should be free.
She knew that all
people should be free.
And she believed in God and
said that the North Star
that we can see on clear nights,
the North Star was the sign
to take her to freedom.
And so she escaped and
won her own freedom.
But she realized she
had an obligation
to help others, too, right?
And so she then returned
often as part
of the Underground Railroad.
And she's known as one
of the great conductors
of the Underground Railroad
where she brought more
than 70 others who had been
held in slavery to freedom.
She was also a nurse,
she was also a spy,
and it's really important
that we celebrate her
many, many achievements.
And that's what this book does.
And I do want to say to
all of you who've not been
out to Maryland's Eastern
shore, we invite you to do that.
There's a national historic
park dedicated to Harriet Tubman
and many other memorials to
her work in Dorchester County
and around Maryland, including
the scenic Underground Railroad
route that you can
take in Maryland.
So thank you all so
much for doing this.
And it is wonderful to have
this team who wrote the book,
and you're going to hear
from again the descendent
of Harriet Tubman.
But I'm grateful to have
the chance to be here just
to say thank you to the Library
of Congress, thank all of you
as we keep alive the work of
Harriet Tubman and recognize
that her bravery and courage
helped change the world,
and you can all help
change the world
for the better going forward.
So thank you all very much.
And --
[ Applause ]
-- unfortunately, I'm
going to have to run.
We're debating the budget.
If you sort of turn on
your cable news station,
we're about to vote
on the budget.
We're putting the final touches
on it, which is good for lots
of reasons including the fact
that that contains the funding
to help the Library of
Congress and programs like this.
So thank all of you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> So Lesa and James,
why don't you come on up?
[ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon.
>> It is a pleasure,
pleasure, pleasure to be here.
We always enjoy visiting
this area,
enjoy visiting Washington,
D.C., and Maryland.
So it's especially nice to
see all these young faces
and to be joined by Mrs.
Wyatt and everyone here
at the Library of Congress.
>> Yes, it's truly
an honor to be here.
We just enjoy coming to
the Capital so often.
And it's a pleasure to have
all of you here today to talk
about this book that we did
that we are so excited about.
It's a wonderful tale -- story
about a person who is a symbol
for all of us to fight
for freedom for everyone
so everyone has the opportunity
to have the type of
life they desire.
So it was really a pleasure
working on this book.
The idea came to me when I was
on a flight probably
coming here.
And I had a copy of Harriet
Tubman on me and I wanted
to do something about her.
Because she's such
a wonderful person,
I think there can't be enough
books about someone like her
for kids to read and be
inspired by her story.
So as I was reading
through this book,
the idea about telling her story
from her being an
elderly person,
going back to when she was young
would be maybe a different way
of telling the story.
But also to highlight
all the different things
that Harriet did.
Because we all know she
freed herself by escaping
and then came back and
helped others escape,
but she also did more than that.
So I wanted to highlight
those things.
I turned to my wife and I said,
how about writing this story?
And she said no [laughs].
I said, but no, come on, it
could be such a great story.
How about if we do it this
way, this way, this way?
She said no [laughs].
So I said, OK, I'm
going to write it.
So I started making some notes,
and I showed her my pitiful,
poor notes, and she says, I
think you have something here,
but I'm going to write it.
And that's why we have the
book we have today [laughs].
>> So although James and I
have been working together
for many years, we've been
married for many more,
one of the things that's most
interesting to people is,
you know, how we collaborate.
And so generally we
collaborate by brainstorming
and James throwing out
tons and tons of ideas,
and generally I tell him that
those ideas are not that great.
So it wasn't that I didn't want
to write the story of Harriet,
it's just that Harriet
has been a heroine
of mine since I was your age.
She was for me the face
of courage and strength,
and I felt almost overwhelmed
by the idea of writing
about your idol, your hero.
And I felt that I didn't
know if I could really write
about her story, or
the idea of writing
about her seemed
so overwhelming.
But when James came
to me with this idea
and I saw the direction that
he was going in, I realized,
OK, let's give it a shot.
We're going to start now
with our presentation,
and we're going to kind of
take you through the process.
And we're going to show you a
little bit about our beginnings
and what inspired us and
share with you a little bit
about before she was Harriet.
>> It's going to show up
at the screen, I believe?
>> Yeah. So we're
going to do forward.
This [inaudible].
>> I think it has
to show up first.
>> Yeah. Here we go.
>> OK.
>> OK. Here we go.
>> So we'll start
at the beginning.
So I am from Massachusetts.
I'm from a town right outside of
Boston, Malden, Massachusetts.
And I grew up there with my
parents, a mother, and --
here I am in kindergarten.
>> Aw.
>> I love to show this picture
because it was really --
it's the last great picture
of myself that I have.
Like, this is the
only picture I have
that I actually really like.
So I grew up there
with my parents.
And I grew up with
my mother, my father,
an older brother and sister.
But this is where I
spent most of my time was
at the Malden Public
Library; and it was there
that I discovered
a love of books.
My mother was really passionate
about reading and writing,
and she shared with
me her love of books.
We used to go every weekend,
we'd take out stacks of books.
And I would bring them home,
and we would just spend
our weekends reading.
And it was there that I
discovered stories about girls
and about adventure and life
beyond Malden, Massachusetts.
I love the stories about
Laura Ingalls Wilder
and Pippi Longstocking and Scout
Finch and all these stories
about these amazing women.
As I got older, I discovered
other stories about women
who were strong and
courageous and tough,
and those are the
stories I really loved,
stories about Sojourner Truth
and Eleanor Roosevelt
and all these women.
And I've always been drawn
to stories about women.
>> I was born in North Carolina
in a small little town
called Rich Square,
just across the Virginia border.
In this little town
with two traffic lights,
I discovered my passion for
drawing and making images.
This is me as a kid.
>> Aw.
>> Thank you [laughs].
>> So cute, so cute.
>> Also, from this
very small town,
we have a writer
named Sheila Moses
who has written books
for older kids.
And we were so proud
to have a writer
and an illustrator
from this small town.
One day Sheila and I are
going to do a book together.
The story The Ledgend
of Buddy Bush is a story
that I heard growing up
as a child and is one
of her most popular books.
So it was in that --
right in front of that --
that car's parked right in front
of the building I was born in.
And growing up in a small
town, there were not a lot
of opportunities for someone
like myself who liked art
since the third grade and
wanted to be an artist.
There was no art taught
in the schools I attended,
there were no museums to go into
see art, there were no artists
to bring me to his
or her studio.
So my first art teachers
came from that pharmacy next
to where I was born, and
they were comic books.
Like so many kids, images
they see on television,
the cartoons they see on
television, comic books are some
of the first art forms we came
in contact with at that time.
So I would copy these images and
make up stories of my friends
and I doing different things.
My own little comment books
I would make as a kid.
I also discovered Mad Magazine.
And this was also a
great inspiration.
Then I moved to New Jersey.
I moved to a suburb of New
York City, and this is me
as a high school student.
I went to Bergenfield High
School, and it was just my luck
that this school had
an amazing art program.
I had someplace where I could
actually talk to teachers
and take classes on
art for the first time
after my freshman
year in high school.
>> So James and I do
lots and lots of books,
we do a lot of picture
book biographies.
And one of the reasons
we're drawn to stories
of African-Americans
and their lives is
because when I was growing
up or when I was your age,
I grew up at a time when there
weren't that many stories
that I could read about
African-American heroes.
And it's really nice to
kind of write stories
about these unknown heroes who
went on to live amazing lives
and do amazing things.
And often these stories
were ones
that I didn't read much about.
And these were people
who weren't names
that were necessarily known;
but they came from very little,
but they went on to do amazing
things and change the world
in ways that were big and small.
And stories like Satchel Paige;
Major Taylor, Champion Cyclist;
and Young Pele, Soccer's
First Star.
Before There Was Mozart,
the story of a young slave
who was born to a mother
who was a slave and a father
who was an owner who
inspired the work of Mozart.
This is a story that
I'd never heard before.
Just a Lucky So and So: The
Story of Louis Armstrong,
who grew up poor but who
felt rich beyond means
because he grew up in a
community surrounded with love
and music and culture.
My Story, My Dance, the
story of Robert Battle.
And Words Set Me Free, which was
a story of Frederick Douglass.
And this was a story
that really inspired me
because as a person who's always
loved reading and education,
I really was motivated by
a story that was inspired
by a slave who wasn't
allowed to learn to read.
It was illegal for
slaves to learn to read,
but Frederick Douglass
equated reading
and education with freedom.
Though he was an enslaved
person, he wanted the freedom
of an education, and he
sought that education out.
And the words that he
discovered, he felt,
allowed him a certain
level of freedom.
And it was my research of
Frederick Douglass that led me
to many other stories.
Go back a little bit.
While I was researching the
story of Frederick Douglass,
I discovered that after he
escaped slavery he found work
in New Bedford at a
whaling ship yard,
and I also discovered
the stories
about a whaling ship captain,
the first African-American
whaling ship captain.
And I started thinking about
perhaps writing a story
about the whaling industry
and about how we once used
to hunt whales but now
we go whale watching.
And I thought, imagine writing
a story about whale watching
versus whaling, and I thought
about bringing those
two stories together.
And that's what I did in
the book Whale Trails,
where I write the story about
a young girl and her father
who own a whale watching boat.
And I also in that book talk
about how 200 years ago,
300 years ago, many escaped
slaves worked on whaling boats.
And that book was Whale
Trails, Before and Now.
And in my research of
Frederick Douglass,
I discovered how many
enslaved peoples --
people also after slavery
-- sought out an education.
And this is a piece of history
that I didn't know about.
And often, I think this
is a piece of history
that was missing
that sometimes we --
African-Americans
were led to believe
that education wasn't important
to us, and yet research
and history shows
us that it was.
This is something that we have
always sought out as a people.
And so this is something I feel
is important for kids to read
about to put in books.
So I wanted to use this in
many of the books that James
and I create together.
And so in my research, I
discovered all these stories
about how many people
sought out an education.
Even in the face of obstacles
and adversity, and that led
to the book Freedom School about
a brother and a sister who went
to the first colored
school in their community,
which was 10 miles from their
home in the book Freedom School.
And the book Light
in the Darkness,
a story about how
slaves learned in secret,
and how these slaves
snuck out late at night
after working a full day in
the fields and how a girl Rosa
and her mom went out
late at night and learned
to read from other slaves.
And of course, they
risked injury,
they risked death,
all to learn to read.
And of course, no story would
be complete without the story
of Harriet Tubman, a
hero of both of ours.
And we felt that her story
needed to be told, but it needed
to be told in a new
way, in a fresh way,
in a way that kids could
understand and respond to very,
very differently and
tell them something new
about Harriet Tubman.
And so Before She Was Harriet,
we found new information
that we wanted to share.
And I'm going to read
to you a little bit now
from Before She Was Harriet.
"Here, she sits an old
woman tired and worn,
her legs stiff, her back achy.
But before wrinkles
formed and her eyes failed,
before she reached her twilight
years, she could walk for miles
and see clearly under a
sky lit only with stars.
Before she was an old
woman, she was a suffragist,
a voice for women who
had none: in marriages,
in courts, in voting booths.
Before her voice became soft and
raspy, it was loud and angry,
rising above injustice.
Before she was a suffragist,
she was General Tubman,
rising out of the fog armed
with courage, strong in the face
of rebels and planters
and overseers,
as they watch fields
burn and bridges fall.
And 700 slaves stop chopping
and start running to a woman
who ferried them to freedom
Combahee River turned
River Jordan.
Before she was General
Tubman, she was a union spy,
carrying secrets
across battlefields
to soldiers fighting
in the Civil War
for President Lincoln
to end slavery.
Before she was a Union spy, she
was a nurse caring for those hit
with bullets and hatred
and fear, tending to them
with bandages and words and the
bloodied dirt of southern soil.
Before she was a nurse, she was
Aunt Harriet, daughter of Ben
and Rit, who helped her
parents flee their master
and find their way through
woods and streams to the safety
of Canada and a new
home in North.
Before she was Aunt
Harriet, she was Moses,
a conductor on Underground
Railroad with no trains
and no tracks, just passengers
traveling to freedom up north,
through swamps, past slave
catchers, across rivers,
under the cover of night,
seeking the Promised Land
for her people led by dreams and
God and faith; a wisp of a woman
with the courage of a lion.
Before she was Moses,
she was Minty of Maryland
of one slave owner and
then others who worked her,
punished her with lashes, broke
her back, but not her spirit.
Before she was Minty, she
was Araminta, a young girl,
taught by her father to read the
woods and the stars at night.
Readying for the day, she'd
leave behind slavery along
with her name, and pick
a new one: Harriet.
And remember her days as a
suffragist, as a general,
as a spy, as a nurse, as
Aunt Harriet, as Moses,
as a conductor, as
Minty, as Araminta,
who dreamed of living long
enough to one day be old, stiff,
and achy, tired, and worn,
and wrinkled, and free."
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> We have a few minutes,
and James is going to do --
>> We going to draw now?
>> -- a little bit of drawing.
>> Yes.
>> I think we have
time for some drawing.
OK.
>> Yes.
>> I need a volunteer
to come up here.
I need someone --
>> Should I sit down?
I'm going to sit down.
>> Sure, yeah.
>> OK.
>> I need someone who
can write a number,
a number between one and ten.
You guys think you can do that?
>> Yeah.
>> OK, how about
this lady right here?
Come on up here.
Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> You see these two dots?
Make a nice, big number.
A number eight, a number
nine, a number ten,
any you want between
one and ten.
It may be hard for her to draw
and hold the mic [laughs].
>> She doesn't need it.
>> Yeah, make a number
between one and 10.
Number one?
OK, good. You can have a seat.
So if you can make the
number one, you can draw.
All you have to do is see
the one as a shape and use
that shape in your drawing.
You get a skier.
[ Applause ]
Who would like to be next?
Someone from over here.
How about the young man in
the back with the scarf on.
>> Whoa.
>> Any number you want.
Good job, number five.
Thank you.
[ Indistinct Chatter ]
A baseball player.
[ Applause ]
Come on up.
Yeah, yeah.
Good job. Number eight.
[ Indistinct Chatter ]
A music conductor.
[ Applause ]
Come on up, with the sweater on.
Number nine.
Good job. This happens to be
one of my favorite numbers
to draw with, number nine.
Ready?
>> Yes.
[ Indistinct Chatter ]
>> A pilot.
Over here?
Can't see?
They can't see.
You need to hold them
up so they can see it
because of where we're angled.
Who over here would
like to come up?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Oh, OK.
OK. Come on up.
[ Applause ]
We did one already.
Oh, you're doing good, good job.
OK, good job.
That's all we have time for?
Yeah, OK. And number 10.
I'll hold it up.
[ Applause ]
That's all we have time
for, guys, I'm sorry.
We have to move on to
another part of our program.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> That was great.
>> Oh, good.
>> I loved it.
>> Thank you [laughs].
>> Thank you both.
And our next presenter
is Ms. Tina Wyatt,
and she's going to come on up.
And I know she's got
a lavalier mic on.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Yeah.
>> Now I mentioned at the
beginning of our program
that we were going to hear from
a senator and from an author
and from an illustrator, and
then I said a descendent.
Can one of you raise your hand
and tell me what
a descendant is?
Yeah?
>> A person from a family.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Say that one more time.
>> Yeah. So when we talk about
someone being a descendent,
we're talking about
someone being descended
from their ancestors, and
that's exactly why when I said
that we were going to have a
descendent of Harriet Tubman
with us, that's exactly
who Ms. Wyatt is.
All right.
I'm going to let you -- Tina,
you get started talking,
and if you want me
to sit with you
and ask questions,
I can do that, too.
>> I'll just start.
Thank you for coming, and
thank you for having me here.
You know, when I look around
and I see all these children
and I think about Aunt
Harriet and who she was
and what she did, the biggest
thing that I can tell you
that is relevant to everyone
is that she was just like you
and she was just like me.
She had hardships,
she had trials;
not just slavery,
but even after.
She had many obstacles
she had to overcome.
And while doing that,
she had fear one time.
And that was when
she first escaped
at the age of 27 in 1849.
She and her brothers set
out -- two of them --
to escape, and they stayed out
for about two or three weeks
and then they returned
because --
mostly because of the fear
of her brothers and
not her as much.
But as soon as they got
back, she set out again.
And the reason why she set out
again is because when she was
around 12 years old, an overseer
from another plantation was
after another enslaved person
and wanted her to stop them
when she came into the store.
And she wouldn't, but
she got in the way.
And he threw a 2-pound
weight, iron weight,
and hit her in the head.
So it fractured or broke her
skull, and it drove in the cloth
that she had around her
head into her skull.
After that, she had
seizures, or what --
you know, sleeping sickness.
And that would happen
anytime, anywhere.
But it was during that
time that God spoke
to her, showed her visions.
Now we all have a
purpose in life.
God brings us here for a reason.
It might be something that we
have to do that's very small,
or it might be something that's
very large, but it all has
to do with each other.
And so when she started having
those visions, she said, not me,
not me, you know, I
don't want to do this.
And so He said, no, I want you
Harriet, I want you to do this.
So she said OK and she
was obedient and she acted
and she went and she did
what He instructed her to do.
So she never did this, never
made a move without Him,
without the instructions
and guidance of the Spirit.
So when she did all
the things that she did
from the time she left and came
back 13 times into the land
where she could be enslaved
again to get her family,
to get her friends, you
know, she didn't stop there.
She continued on.
And the reason why -- and
this is what I really want
to impress upon you children
-- is that it's about love,
and she embodied that love.
She embodied that
selflessness and what the word
of God says, love your neighbor.
And that is exactly what
she did throughout her life,
sometimes to her own detriment
to where people would
take advantage of her.
But she went on -- everywhere
she went, she was home;
everywhere she went, she made a
home for those who had no home;
for people who had no family,
she became their family.
And she would take her own
money and she would see
to whatever need they had.
When she came here to
Washington from getting orders
to be commissioned
in the military --
and she was commissioned.
It is documented.
She was commissioned to be
in the military and serve
in the Civil War, as
James and Lee had told you
about as a scout,
a spy, a nurse.
But she was the first
woman, black or white,
to lead a military raid, and
she did it on the Combahee River
in South Carolina where she
brought up over 700 slaves.
She freed them.
And then after that --
see, the job wasn't done.
For her, the job was not done.
Because what are they
going to do after that?
How will they earn a living?
How will they take
care of themselves?
So what she did was she took her
own money, $200 that she had --
all that she had -- and
set up a wash house.
She set up a kitchen.
And she taught them, you
have skills; you have skills,
and you have a passion;
use it to earn a living.
She showed them how to market
those things that they did,
who to give it to,
who to sell it to.
She did all of that.
So I want you to understand
that she had many obstacles.
You know, the term
courageous, heroic,
all those adjectives
are said about her.
But like I said, she was
just like you and me.
She had to overcome
many obstacles,
and she did not let
anything stop her.
She didn't let it get her down.
One time she walked out into
a water that she did not know.
Most of the time, she knew
the waterways because that's
where she was raised
in Maryland,
and she knew the
waterways and the land,
and she worked alongside
her father
who did -- who was a timberman.
He, you know, brought down the
trees and things like that,
and she was there with him.
So she knew the land, and she
talked to watermen who were free
that came down through Maryland.
And there, she learned about
what was going on in other parts
of the world other
than where she was.
So she took all this in.
Everything that she went through
became a lesson and a guide
for her as she went on her way.
But as she kept doing this and
going further and going further
and going further, she
never forgot about the needs
of others; that was always
first and foremost in her mind.
And after the Civil War,
she went back to her home.
And the one reason why --
she had to make a decision
during the Civil War.
She had to make a decision
during the Civil War,
and that was to either stay
or go back to take care
of her parents who were in need.
And that's where she
fought for her pension.
She did not receive her
pension until many years later,
and that was as a nurse.
She got it for her
husband first.
But what did she do back
on her farm in Auburn?
Again, the needs of others.
She set up a home for the aged,
for the sick, for the indigent.
It was always first and
foremost on her mind.
And she did this all
through God showing her what
to do, and she obeyed.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much, Tina.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> There are a couple
of microphones
out there floating around.
And I suspect that you all
might have some questions
for our author, our
illustrator, and our descendent.
So if you have a question,
please raise your hand
and make sure that
one of my friends
that has a microphone
can get to you.
And you can say your name
and then you can go ahead
and ask your question.
Very good.
>> Hi, I'm Daniel Shepherd
[assumed spelling].
So -- OK. So Harriet
Tubman was a Christian?
>> Yes. Yeah, absolutely,
yes, she was.
Very religious.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Prayed throughout most
of her escapes [laughs].
I think most of us would
if we were escaping.
>> Mm-hmm.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Sure.
>> Hi. My name is Yasneve
[phonetic] and I have
to ask you a question is,
how old was Harriet Tubman
when she was a nurse?
>> How old was she?
>> She was probably
in her 40's --
>> Yeah, I don't know.
>> -- around that time.
>> They didn't have birth
certificates at that time, so --
especially for slaves,
it wasn't really marked
when they were born, so
it's hard to tell exactly --
>> Mm-hmm.
>> -- how old she was.
>> But she was 27
when she escaped.
We know that she
was born in 1822,
but we don't know the date.
And so it was 1849,
so you kind of got
to do the math a little bit.
So she was, like, in her
40's, somewhere around there.
>> Another question?
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> Hello. My name is
Violet [assumed spelling].
Did some white people like her?
>> Oh, sure.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you want to say --
>> Yes. I mean, I'm sure that
some white people liked her,
but I'm also sure that some
white people didn't like her.
You know, what she was doing
was essentially what --
in their minds, they saw her
as stealing their property.
But what they were doing was
stealing away their own freedom.
So I think that there
might have been a conflict
that they saw that
was happening.
So, yeah, I'm sure that --
but there were white people
who were also fighting
for the freedom
of African-Americans
and there were --
>> In Newark.
>> -- white soldiers
who were fighting, also.
So yes, I'm sure
there were both.
>> And, you know, a part
of her network was called
the Underground Railroad.
And that was a network
of people, not trains,
but a network of people that
were in secret that helped her.
And a lot of them were
white that helped her.
So you had to know where to
go, and -- and Thomas Garrett,
which was really a good
friend of hers, you know,
when she would come
and she'd want money.
And one time he told her, he
said, well, if you're coming
for somebody else, I'm not going
to give it to you, Harriet.
But she told him, she said,
well, you're going to give it
to me because it is
for somebody else.
So, yeah.
>> I think we have a question
on this side in purple.
>> Hi. My name is
Mykia [phonetic].
Why do you like to draw?
>> Oh. There's something
magical about it.
When I was very young, I
wanted to be a magician.
But, you know, you have
a white piece of paper
and you have something -- a
drawing instrument in your hand,
and just by passing that drawing
instrument across the paper,
you create shapes and images
that people appreciate.
And that's one of the many
reasons why I love to draw
because you can make
something and you can see it,
what you made, almost instantly.
>> Good question.
>> OK. I see a couple
of hands going up.
>> Hi. My name is Sarah
[assumed spelling].
How long did it take
you guys to make a book?
>> Well, it takes a long time
to make a book because you have
to do the research, and
then you do the writing
and then you revise it
and you revise it again.
So generally for me,
it takes about --
let's say about six
months to write the book.
And then it goes off
to the illustrator,
and then sometimes the
illustrator can take --
>> Yeah. Can I say --
>> Yeah.
>> The illustrator
would take about --
it takes me about a year to
illustrate a book, right?
It has to come from
Lesa, it comes to me,
and it takes about a year.
>> And then it takes
about another --
>> Year.
>> -- year or two
to print the book.
So it takes a pretty
long time to make a book.
>> Good question.
>> All right.
Over here in the yellow.
>> Hi. My name is Jairo
Torres [phonetic].
And when she was a slave, when
she tried to escape to houses,
she saw [inaudible]
to give her clues
that that was a safe house.
>> Thank you.
A comment.
>> OK. All right.
Go ahead.
>> I didn't understand --
>> Hi. My name is Natasha
[assumed spelling].
And when are you guys
going to make a new book?
>> When are we going
to make a new book?
We're always making new books.
We have a book coming out in May
about Venus and Serena Williams.
I have a novel coming out,
and then we're always
working on new projects.
>> Great question.
>> How -- no, no, no.
>> Are you sure?
>> Yeah.
>> It's all right.
We'll come back.
>> When Harriet Tubman slept,
did they hit her instantly
when she fell asleep?
>> When she did what?
>> When she fell asleep.
>> Uh-huh?
>> Did they hit her?
>> To wake her up?
No. You know, everyone knew what
happened to her, so the people
around her would always
just say, well, you know,
there she is, she's
going off again.
So they would wait
until she woke up.
>> OK. Yeah.
>> Hello, my name is
Brian [assumed spelling].
My question is, how did
the illustrator become a
good drawer?
>> Lots of years of practicing,
which is a lot of fun
because I love drawing.
So as a kid I drew a lot.
High school.
Then I went to college.
I studied art in
college, illustration.
And after I graduated, I
continued to take classes.
I go to museums and
I look at art.
I continue to practice and draw.
If you like drawing,
it's a fun job
because you're basically doing
what you love all the time.
>> All right.
>> Good answer.
I think you've -- nope,
maybe not [laughs].
Yes?
>> Hi, my name is Janet
[assumed spelling].
And my question is, what
was the thing she got hit
with made out of?
>> Pardon me?
>> The thing that --
what was it made out of?
>> What was the thing
that she got hit out of --
>> Oh, iron.
>> Iron.
>> Iron, yeah.
>> Very heavy.
>> It was quite a blow, also.
It really did change her
life, that blow to the head.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Yes.
>> My name is Fabiola
[phonetic], and I want to know
who in your family
supported you in illustrating?
[ Laughter ]
>> Actually, my --
I grew up with my --
I lived with my grandmother
for about 16 years,
and she really supported my art.
She always bought me supplies,
allowed me to buy
different supplies,
and she was my biggest
supporter.
>> Good question.
All right.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> My name is Samaya
[phonetic], and I want to know,
if Harriet Tubman
was alive today,
what advice would she give us?
>> Oh.
[ Chuckling ]
>> Nice.
[ Applause ]
>> Careful now.
Be careful.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, what I think she
would do is tell you to --
>> Do well in school.
>> Yeah.
>> I believe education
would probably be --
>> Yeah.
>> -- a very important thing.
>> Yeah, because it was
taken away from her.
>> Yeah.
>> She couldn't read,
she couldn't write.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> But I think she would
also tell you to stand
up for what you believe
and to love others
because that's what she did.
>> Yeah.
>> Great questions.
>> You know, a lot of things --
you know, one other thing I want
to say is that because
there's a lot of bullying going
on in schools today, and,
you know, of people saying,
I don't like you,
and trying to get
other people not
to associate with other people.
You know, she would
tell you to not do that.
You know, to find something --
because there's always something
in everyone that you can find
-- you know, that you can like.
>> Mm-hmm, all.
>> Yeah, and that
there's something
that you can connect with.
>> Yeah.
>> OK. One more question,
I think.
>> Hi, my name is Dillon
[assumed spelling].
When did you guys
publish your first book?
>> My first book was published
in 1990, a long time ago.
And your book was --
>> Yeah. Our first book
together was published in 2000.
>> Yeah.
>> Very nice.
>> Very good.
Good, guys.
[ Applause ]
So I want to thank you
all for your questions.
I also want to thank
you for your listening
because I was really good.
It's hard to sit still for
this long and be as attentive
as you all have been,
so thank you for that.
I want to show you
two little pictures
up on these screens here.
When Senator Van Hollen was
talking with you, he mentioned
that the Library of Congress
and the national Museum
of African American History
and Culture had recently
worked together
to acquire a new scrapbook
that includes a previously
before not seen image
of Harriet Tubman.
And you guys are each
going to get a copy
of that photograph today, but
you're also going to get a copy
of a photograph that
we've seen before.
How many of you have
seen this photograph
of Harriet Tubman before?
Yeah, it's kind of
a famous photograph.
And it really reflects
Harriet Tubman
at the later part of her life.
And the new photograph
of Harriet Tubman --
>> What?
>> It says right
there Nurse Tubman.
>> -- is this one.
>> Yeah.
>> And you can see that it's
significantly years prior
to the one we just saw.
This is the new image that
we believe was taken in 1868
of her, so we have a sense
of what she might have looked
like when she was
in her late 40's.
Remember at the beginning
of this talk
when I mentioned how we
could describe people
like Thomas Jefferson and
James Madison and John Adams
in all those ways, and I
introduced Senator Van Hollen,
and I described him as
many different things
in addition to being a senator?
In the story that the
Ransomes read to us,
we learned a little bit
about Harriet Tubman
and the various roles
that she played.
Can one of you raise your
hand and tell me one thing
that Harriet Tubman was?
What was one thing that -- yeah?
What was she?
>> Moses.
>> She was Moses.
Excellent, yeah.
She was a conductor on
the Underground Railroad
and referred to as Moses.
That was awesome.
What else was she?
Yeah, in the yellow.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> I can't hear you.
Sorry.
>> She was a fugitive.
She was a fugitive.
>> I still didn't hear you.
I'm sorry.
>> A fugitive.
>> Oh, she was a fugitive, yeah.
Yes, she was.
OK, what else was she?
In the purple.
>> She was a nurse.
>> She was a nurse, excellent.
And right here in the
middle, what was she?
>> A spy.
>> She was a spy, yeah.
I heard him, yep.
Yeah. So she was a nurse,
she was a spy, she was Moses.
Anything else?
>> A nurse!
>> Yeah.
>> She was a slave.
>> She was enslaved early in
her life, but what else was she?
>> She was a scout.
You guys are good.
Yeah. So Harriet Tubman
was lots of things.
And just to repeat, the images
that you have give us a glimpse
of what she looked like at
different stages in her life.
And the book that you
are all receiving a copy
of is the Ransomes' book
about before she was Harriet.
And I hope that you
keep in mind that --
like, right now you guys are all
students, but I know that some
of you are athletes and some
of you already are artists.
And I know that some of you
like to cook, so you must be,
like, brilliant chefs.
But you are a lot of things.
And you are also all of the
things that you're going
to become, and that's
exciting to think about.
It's exciting to think
about welcoming you all back
here someday to talk to us
about the books that
you've written or the books
that you've illustrated.
So thank you for coming to
the Library of Congress today.
Thank you very much for
your attentiveness --
[ Applause ]
-- and your questions.
And we are looking forward
to having you back again.
Thank you again, Lesa and James.
[ Applause ]
Thank you as well, Tina.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.